[Music]
here we go again sony have announced the
ps plus essential games for the month of
september 2022. as always the following
three games are yours to download from
the first tuesday of the month which is
september the 6th this month we have a
racer a fighter and a photography game
let's go first up we have our annual
racing game this time it's need for
speed heat in the past need for speed
games have been a bit hit and miss but
with all things considered heat is
excellent set in palm city which looks
to be based on miami we progress through
a story which is like a homage to the
first fast and furious film the real
impressive part of heat are the two
modes available day and night by day
you'll be taking part in legal races
sponsored events behind safety barriers
but at night we delve into the illegal
racing underworld speeding through the
streets by moonlight fending off traffic
cops who never back down we can switch
between each mode manually and that
allows us to choose the types of races
we want to take part in oh and it should
be noted this is very much an arcade
game many trees and brick walls can be
plowed straight through to keep your
momentum high need for speed heat
utilizes real car licenses so expect
ferraris everywhere and when you get
your own every part of that vehicle is
customizable from paint jobs and decals
to tuning the engine and upgrading
almost any part of your car like a
digital mechanic the hook is seeing a
part you need in the garage racing for
the cash to buy it then upgrading your
ride to challenge the next tier of races
rinse and repeat the average score for
need for speed heat is 7.5 out of 10 so
it's worth our time next we have tome on
ps5 and yes the game really is black and
white from start to end tome is all
about the joy of photography and has a
play time of about three hours maybe
four if you want the platinum trophy it
is not here to take over your life it's
a one-and-done tome gives us a basic
camera and tasks us with helping the
inhabitants of this world after we've
assisted so many a new area opens up
with more people to meet help and take
selfies with eventually you'll be given
a tripod to set up your camera perfectly
and even a horn to startle people and
animals into some strange poses but
you'll need to be quick to capture them
tome will have you snapping images of
bigfoot hiding away and ant going about
their day almost unnoticeable to the
naked eye reviews average at 8 out of 10
making this the best game of the month
and i think it's worth three hours of
your time for that platinum trophy at
least and finally grand blue fantasy
versus a 2.5 d fighter from 2020 it
turns out over 20 million people play
the mobile rpg or watch the anime so
this franchise is massive versus takes
the spirit of street fighter and keeps
it simple using the typical light medium
and heavy attacks and a special two the
real devastating combos happen when
players are trapped in the corner by an
invisible wall that's when controllers
are smashed granblue fantasy versus has
an rpg mode to advance through which
takes about 10 hours to complete that
mode gives us new weapons to find and
unlock and upgrade to make attacks more
powerful all while following an episodic
timeline and minimally animated visuals
grand blue fantasy verses may be a tough
sell but the critics tell us it's a
solid 7.5 out of 10. so will you try it
so did you get to this part of the video
before clicking off if yes thank you
very much do me a favor please be sure
to rate the month in the comments below
and tell me what you're playing for me
i'm playing tom and i'm probably gonna
go back to play eat again what about you
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time